Okay so we know how to get data into a
MongoDB collection. And do queries against that collection. Now I
would like to talk about briefly, is how to remove
documents from a collection where that's necessary. So the syntax for
removing documents is actually quite similar to the syntax for
finding documents. So with find if we want to return all
the documents in the collection we simply don't express any
parameters to the find function. The same is true with remove
if I were to execute this query it would remove
one by one all of the cities from this collection.
A more efficient way of doing that would simply be
to call drop which would remove the entire collection and
any meta data associated with it. Such as indexes. Now,
we can also remove individual documents or documents matching particular
criteria. So, for example, I could remove an individual document
with the name matching the value "Chicago." So, let me
first do a find and there we see that single city. And now, a remove. And then
to find again, and sure enough, that city's gone
from this collection. Now let's look at a query
that touches more than one document. So in
this case, what I want to do is identify all
documents that don't actually have a name. Okay, you
can see there are several returned, in fact 210
documents in this city's collection may seem odd. Don't actually
have a name. This is a good example here. We've got
a country, but no name for the individual city. Same is
true with the rest of these returned. Now, as part of
a cleaning pass, for example, we might want to remove all cities
from this collection after they've been put into the database, all
cities that don't actually have a value for the name field.
I can do that by sending this same query document to
the remove function. So now, I've removed all of those
cities that have no name and if I do a
find again I can see that there are now in
fact no cites that are missing a name field, so
the take away here is that remove works in a
way very similar to find, you can specify the document
to be removed using a query document that has the
same syntax and operators available as does the find function.